lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
darles un buen entendimiento de cómo
funciona el rango de impuestos federales
a las ganancias en eeuu y también
veremos lo que significa caer en otro
rango de impuestos o tener un aumento en
el rango digamos que yo gano 100.000
dólares soy soltera y no voy a entrar en
deducciones sofisticadas así que digamos
que yo gano 100 mil dólares en un año y
estos números cambian conforme van
cambiando los años pero la idea general
es la misma aunque algunos detalles
podrían cambiar la forma en que
funcionan estos rangos es que en los
primeros 8 mil 350 de mis 100 mil
dólares tendrán un impuesto del 10 por
ciento así que los primeros 8 mil 250
dólares tendrán un impuesto del 10% y de
esto estará pagando 800 35 dólares de
estos primeros 8 mil 350 dólares
ahora en los siguientes 25 mil 600
dólares oa partir de 8 mil 350 hasta 33
mil 950 ese rango tendrá un impuesto del
15 por ciento así que esta cantidad de
aquí tendrá que pagar el 15 por ciento
de ella
la diferencia entre 33 mil novecientos
cincuenta menos ocho mil trescientos
cincuenta es 25 mil seiscientos lo
escribo aquí y a estos veinticinco mil
seiscientos los voy a multiplicar por el
15% y esto lo calculará al final usando
la calculadora ahora para los siguientes
48 mil 300 dólares tendrán un impuesto
del 25 por ciento vamos a dibujarlo en
otro color lo ponemos para acá este
siguiente rango ya que tendrá un
impuesto del 25 por ciento así que la
diferencia entre 82 mil 250 y 33 mil 950
son 48 mil 300 los escribimos 48 mil 300
x 25
y finalmente lo que queda que está por
encima de los 82 mil 250 y ya que no
alcanzó el siguiente rango a esta parte
cita de acá se le aplicará un impuesto
del 28 por ciento así que esta parte de
aquí tendrá 28 por ciento de impuestos
ahora si sacamos nuestra confiable
calculadora para encontrar estos valores
la diferencia entre 100.000 dólares y 82
mil 250 lo escribimos
cien mil dólares menos 82 mil 250 que es
lo que vamos a aplicarle un impuesto del
28 por ciento es 17 mil 750
a 17.750 por 28% usamos nuevamente la
calculadora para encontrar estos valores
por lo que vamos a hacerlo todo de una
vez
17.750
por el 28 por ciento digamos que es
punto 28 más 48 mil 348 1300 por punto
25 1600 por el 15%
es punto 15
esta cantidad 835 dólares así que
nuestro resultado es que voy a pagar 21
mil 720 dólares de impuestos todo esto
la suma de todo esto el total es de 21
mil ya se me olvidó la cantidad 21 mil
720 dólares y bien se cuenta que sólo se
está pagando el 28 por ciento de la
parte incremental que tengo dentro de
ese rango no se paga el 28 por ciento de
toda la cantidad de estos 100 mil sólo
el incremento que se encuentra por
encima de los 82 mil 250 tampoco se paga
el 25 por ciento de todo esto sólo el
incremento que cae del rango